right yeah what are your thoughts on
just everything Kanye from the last two
weeks or so it's been a rough two weeks
I'll let you jump on that it's been a
lot started it started with the wildlife
matter thing which was like okay
this guy's true I felt like he was just
trolling for the wrong reasons real
hurtful yeah but no kids got some
interesting thoughts
Drake Champs interview is wild
wild yeah
um
Kanye West is kind of the leader
of a really really interesting movement
right there's there's a time in the last
several years where
group think right right being contrarian
to group think
is being accepted as intelligence right
if I just think the opposite of what
everybody else is thinking then I'm
gonna just show everybody how
how on top of it I am right no research
no studying no information just whatever
everybody seems to be saying say the
opposite I'm gonna say the opposite and
I'm going to show you guys how free
thinking I am right which isn't
irresponsible if you just work down the
street at Panda Express and that's just
what you want to get off your chest but
when you have the stature and the
influence of someone like Mr West he's
probably the most influential human
being ever it's grossly irresponsible
yeah and if you've noticed he's
developed a bit of a zealot following
where in their minds he can't do or say
anything wrong even if it's blatantly
and flagrantly untrue We can't agree on
what's facts anymore I think people are
just more likely to forgive Kanye
because they love his music so much yeah
there's that and they love his shoes and
they but I feel like that only goes so
far and I think he might have hidden
that he might he's might have hit that
wall of like people he has some people
with him though Kev that want to also be
viewed as Leaders of in the in the free
thought space right and they think that
by again just bucking the trend of
whatever I'm contrarian about and my
circles and on Instagram and on Twitter
I can be viewed as free thinking and and
of a higher level of intelligence just
by saying the opposite of whatever is
popular accepted opinion even when
popular accepted opinion is based on
fact right I'm just going to say the
opposite so I can show you guys how woke
and and learned I am and he's the leader
of that school yeah it really really is
as you can see
um I think it's kind of spinning out of
control yeah with trying to come across
as a leader it's it's pretty wild good
because technically he is a leader the
problem is is he doesn't carry himself
like he has those responsibilities yeah
and like uh you know I think that uh
some of the anti-semitic [ __ ] he's
saying is crazy it's so hurtful it's
just wild yeah and
so like he said he had said something
like Jewish people have controlled
black voices for so long
and if you if if you feel that way
can't you just say black people it's
time we start controlling our voices
without mentioning without mentioning
another absolutely especially when
you're the self-proclaimed richest black
man in the history of the United States
you sir can absolutely yeah create that
space where we own our own stories our
own voice and our own platform right
like even with the Trump thing like
I understood what he was trying to do he
was trying to push the line that says
hey the Democratic party been taking
advantage of black voters this whole
entire time
let me show y'all you don't have to like
when he really explained it out I was
like well I get the what he's trying to
do but the way he did it you can do that
without him you could just say it buddy
or you could yeah you could say it
without looking like you're [ __ ] your
hug like he looked like a a kid who met
his favorite celebrity I mean he called
the guy a father figure he was like his
dad like come on dude yeah and so I
think like Kanye is just very
um
he's just very the way he communicates
what he thinks to be right is just so
short-sighted and it's just very like
it's like dude like like the White lives
matter thing he's like I think he what
did he say he said
um
black lives matter was a scam there I
ended it and it's like you could be very
you know
um
critical of black lives matter the
organization yes as Kanye West yes and B
and point out a lot of [ __ ] but what is
the point of doing that while also
putting on a shirt that says white lives
about it I want to add to that though
because you know I I hear a lot of that
stuff you know but for someone in that
position you have to bear in mind that
well there's a bunch of different
there's a bunch of different black lives
matter sure organization let me let me
say this okay so I come from the
tradition of
uh so my teacher Dr Camille West yeah
you know her shout out Dr Westin shout
out Dr westenberg
um made sure that I learned
what movements look like what struggles
look like you know what I mean so we
learned from the Panthers we learn from
you know uh all these these
organizations these individuals with
with groups and and movements around
them you know the stokleys the the
Baldwins James Baldwin all these folks
right and these folks that had
contrarian opinions that that ran
against what was popular in the country
at the time and you know people used
every trick in the book to uh frame
folks as being this that or the other
right
um just because you know these are
information Wars right this is it's a
matter of influencing public opinion if
you can make Dr King look like the most
evil human being who ever lived most
when Dr King was like most people
opposed his views most now it's all good
because he's been rebranded right so I
take when people talk bad about BLM the
organization I take that with a grain of
salt I I also add to it that BLM has
done a lot since Trayvon Martin died in
2012 right it's been around since then
right and they've done a lot of good
things and every organization deserves
to be able to grow up you know the
Kennedys the Great American family they
got their money they got their start in
prohibition
in prohibition mean they were selling
illegal products in the United States of
America that's how they got their money
were able to attain political
um status in this country
um and and you know they they say most
most every uh Fortune is built on the
back of a crime or something like that
there's a popular saying
um which I don't believe necessarily
that BLM has done anything criminal
they've just done things that perhaps
most folks don't agree with in terms of
how things should be spent ins based on
what I've read they haven't like robbed
any banks or killed any people or
anything yeah I just think that there's
a lot of criticism a lot of the victims
that
um
have obviously been highly publicized
that has fueled their movements or have
not reaped the benefits sure and that's
uh where there's a lot of the higher-ups
in Black lives matter who are
millionaires now that weren't
millionaires prior to you're saying the
same thing as me so in terms of your
opinion on how they spend money you know
it's not illegal like you said they're
not criminals right so who's to say but
you know I know this one Kanye West to
be so critical of something without
giving a context without knowing himself
without having walked in those shoes
right I feel like that's kind of a a
tough I remember reading a story about
BLM
um and I don't want to act like the
great defender of BLM but I just don't
hear the other side of it in the media
and because I've seen this in history
right again I take it with a grain of
salt but the other side of this is
um one of the stories that I've seen was
BLM
bought a a house a mansion something
like this I was framed and then I had to
do some investigation because obviously
we do the show right you have to talk
about it yeah right I did some
investigation and the way BLM was
looking at that purchase was like no
this was a facility we have to have a
place that's protected where they can't
put bugs on the wall and tap stuff we
can't be renting a place we can't you
know we have to have something with a
gate we have to with certain
requirements where we can House people
you know whatever and this place
afforded us all of these uh things that
we needed and so this was a reasonable
purchase for a business like out or for
a movement organization like ours right
and for anyone else that had an opinion
prior to reading that that article they
would look at it like okay of course
these black people got this money and
now they're spending it they're they're
throwing parties or whatever and that's
the way the article framed it but when
we dig it one layer deeper ask one
person a question you get the a little
bit more context you're like okay that
makes sense it's entirely reasonable and
it's not this nefarious operation and so
again Kanye West or whoever else who's
been critical but you know this is the
person we're talking about right now him
saying these things again is very
hurtful because it's very easy to
support
someone black if you're the same Kanye
West who goes on the news and says
George Bush doesn't care about black
people these are my people out here when
my people go in the store they say that
they're looting but when it's white
people that go into the store this is
about Katrina him talking about right
right when when white people go in the
store they're getting supplies because
they're desperate when my people go in
the store Kanye West said that right and
then he said George Bush doesn't care
about black people I remember watching
that yeah I remember watching that so if
that's the same person who can give a
little bit of Grace and understanding
and context to a conversation for him to
then take it all away from BLM who's
been active on the street I haven't seen
Kanye West in any protest you know
clearly not the same person though but
yeah sure sure but you know I'm holding
them to that standard that he set for
himself right I've seen BLM since 2012
I've been at the library right with
these people in small little meetings
with Dr westenberg because I'm the
person on the radio in my city and
there's like there's very like localized
chapters yeah sure yeah so there's like
a black lives matter La there's a black
lives matter Phoenix Metro
so all of those are very like separate
from I think I think I think you can't
just paint the whole thing with one
brush right but I do think that in the
same way we're talking like Candace
Owens is capitalizing off of everything
she's looking at it through I think a
lot of people are doing it on the other
side too sure sure yeah I mean listen
it's not impossible that these things
because I know this I just talked to
Killer Mike so I call Killer Mike and
I'm like yo where do I donate my money
and if Killer Mike tells me don't donate
it there donate it here I'm like cool
listen I just talked to Dr Camilla
westenberg and I tell you what if
somebody comes down my street and says
hey we would like to acquire the federal
trademark to create and produce and sell
white lives anything that says white
lives matter on it I know that the NAACP
is ready and willing to receive a check
from Civic Cipher LLC you know what I'm
saying and then I know some people like
you said there are local chapters the
people that I've seen do the work the
people that inspired Civic Cipher
there's a woman named Zara tacola you
know I love her to death She's My Shiro
you know what she's doing she has a
501c3 they do Grassroots uh work in in
Arizona
um and you know nationally she has a
national profile I would love to donate
money to her because I believe it
because you know her I was going to say
if people want to help out how do they
vet where they should put their money
well you can start by donating the Civic
Cipher you can hit civicsipher.com
because we are on it you know I risked
my whole career to to bring some like I
was the man I was doing my thing you
know what I'm saying yeah I'm telling
you like I got to convince you but you
know we was there together right but um
yeah I'm I'm I we have a segment on our
show called uh Baba become a better Ally
right it comes from one of the African
languages it means father as well so
sort of a reference to like guidance or
whatever right become a better Ally
um and that segment we often talk about
the NAACP right so it's the oldest most
uh established organization that that
moves in such a way to try to create
more opportunities and more political uh
strength for impoverished communities
black and brown you know I I do believe
we do believe in unity between all
marginalized groups of people so you'll
see me you hear me say black and brown a
lot
um but I I also mean you know our aapi
brothers and sisters I mean our native
brothers and sisters uh indigenous
brothers and sisters our lgbtqia plus
brothers and sisters anybody you nailed
it if you were born if you feel like you
were born with a strike against you and
you want to join a movement where love
is at the center of the conversation
where we are trying to to make sure
everybody has a voice and it's heard and
it's protected
um and there's equality as as far as we
can take that then then that's the
movement that you want to be on and we
didn't ask to be in this position again
you know with all these stations
carrying our message around this whole
entire country but now that we're here
there's an even greater responsibility
to be true to it and you know if they
bury my my sons carrying me on my last
day and they bury me in the ground and
the last thing I did was record an
episode of Civic Cipher I'd still say
this was a life well lived